Now you might be going through these
exercises, and they seem pretty logical
to you but you're still staring
at a barren desert of zero ideas.
That's okay, seriously,
it happens to the best of us.
And when this happens to me,
I actually go outside.
I go for a walk or swim or
I just sit in the park.
And I find that just being outside
really helps me get creative,
but this might not work for you.
You might want to browse Reddit and
look at funny pictures or
get inspiration from friends or family.
If you don't have any ideas right now,
the important thing is just
do whatever works for you.
Find some way to get into
a creative mindset and
really just start brainstorming.
Don't worry if your ideas are stupid,
don't worry if you don't
think you can implement them.
Write anything down because you'll
never know what might come of it.